oh playing a gm okay
who is this probably anonymous
anonymous
okay this is the first stafford gamut
accepted of the stream
opponent knows what to do opponent
actually knows what to do
so knight g4 is kind of the objectively
best
move i think but h5
h5 is still interesting jonathan trance
had a video recently
where he beat stockfish with h5 it was
actually a really cool game
okay we're going into the line that i
played against levy
um
you remember what i missed against levy
i know bishop f3 there's castling
okay i might as well get my pawn cube
the indestructible pawn
cube of greatness yeah let's go
don't mess with my pawn cube
it's so beautiful it's so square
but what do i do now
i have six i'm just down upon
oh that's okay my pawn cube will
hopefully save me
never too late to castle
we're basically in an end game
so i have a bishop versus knight
oh if i play this it's no longer a cube
but do i do it anyway there's also this
move
so the helicopter that's a helicopter
like g6 some idea
i had plus five against someone with a
stafford porn cube
we all know what happened in the end
h4 was a good move
let's play
actually don't know what to do here is
rook d4
or d4 idea rook t8
lights coming to e3
let's start with this yeah so there's no
c3 because i take it
and i guess i want to advance the cube
yeah now it's a pawn it's a social
distance cubed
kind of
i could i could make a sandwich
to put the rooks i don't know rook
sandwich or king sandwich or both
it also like un develop everything
so many possibilities in life
at least i'm up on time oh white doesn't
know what to do
it's nice if this maybe i'm taking
probably doesn't work no it doesn't work
look at this i just moved back and and
the pawn's a bit more weak
it's probably contemplating this move
i probably take and play this
or i just play this immediately
i probably rock a chain immediately
opponent very confused
thanks for subbing by the way mr
something something
okay so opponent wants to play d4 bishop
b3 here
might as well just kind of chill repair
the advancement of the cube
so rook d1 i always have bishop b3
oh that's a move
oh what do i do against that
takes in c5 doesn't quite work
[Music]
that's probably a good move
b6
you can probably see four there's also
bishop b3 immediately is interesting
because now that i prevent rook d1
and i don't know if i can actually
exploit the pin
but i want to okay i just have to move
back i
guess yeah that didn't work at all
it's kind of sad
okay oh there's this idea now it's a
pawn
chain of some sort
that's a good move i can take maybe e4
is weak
let's start with this
f5 f5 is kind of no it doesn't do
anything
did this move
i'm just trying to hold my ground
if i take the check
does this work
i don't know if it works i also have g5
here
g5 is probably the way to go it's not
pretty though
oh that's defended
this move
uh richie oh no my pawn
oh but white doesn't do it
what's going on here am i surviving
no no
my cube my cube of greatness
ah oh there goes all my pawns
i feel so broken
opponent opponent destroyed my
indestructible pawn cube
that's so sad i got a king pawn ending
with equal material but this is probably
winning already for white
yeah i like winning here
that was a beautiful game too trying to
resist
as much as possible
yeah i guess it was a temporary cube
and for those saying it was a square
it's three-dimensional
if it survives through time
that's so sad though anyway that might
that the game might still go on youtube
a grandmaster destroys my indestructible
pawn cube